from 2008 to 2013 or 14 i would say was
really can india find product
marketplace and then the second phase
was can indian companies scale india is
also reaching that inflection point
where the rest of the world they will be
seeking inspiration from us china and
india and india will play a massive role
and i'll tell you why all right guys
bang bang i've got shiva here with me
i'm very excited about this and i
thought a great place to start is uh
just the country of india in general
obviously most people know it's a very
large country
1.4 billion people talk to me a little
bit in terms of the culture of india and
why is entrepreneurship kind of having
this renaissance or this resurgence
within the country
yeah so let me start by um giving you a
maybe let me start with the
you know global world view on the tech
in general
right uh
u.s pioneered
china came along china started seeking
inspiration from u.s uh they tried in
the beginning they were mostly copying
and carrying ideas from from us and
building it
and then you know china reached an
inflection point where they had a bunch
of uh
you know massive companies like alibaba
tencent and all that stuff and they
could really build their entire
ecosystem moving forward meaning they
were they had capital and they had
talent
then you know chinese entrepreneurs
started
building ideas and companies really
unique to themselves solving china's
specific problems and then you then
india has been there india has been
seeking inspiration from us and it's
been taking inspiration from china
and uh
and and you know now india is also
reaching that inflection point where
you know india has about
i think it's about 105 uh unicorns now
india has capital both basically talent
and capital
and moving forward i think
you know the rest of the world which is
emerging world uh they will be seeking
inspiration from u.s china and india and
india will play a massive role up and
i'll tell you why in a bit so let me
talk about indian technology because
it's now how it has evolved over the
years
uh we'll we'll go back in 1990s in the
beginning it was mostly about call
centers it was about uh you know ppo
meaning small jobs that were not really
core to your business
and then tcs uh you know infosys came
along they started providing i.t
services to u.s companies and then
a lot of companies for example microsoft
facebook bunch of these uh companies
they started opening up tech uh you know
centers in india because they could tap
into the tech talent
the real technology ecosystem or the
startup ecosystem i would say started in
2008 that's when the company companies
like somato flipkart bunch others got
founded and
i would say i would view
startup ecosystem of india just like a
startup from 2008 to
2013 or 14 i would say was really can
india
find product market meaning can you
really build companies can you build
startups in india
that got uh proven right and then the
second phase was
from 2014 to 2020 21
which is can indian companies scale uh
and i think the first inflection point
was when
flipkart got funded uh it was valued at
a billion dollars so that kind of like
story got kind of uh
you know really uh proven
and in 2021
we saw about 39 billion went into the
indian startups uh
44 unicorns got minted overall we have
105. so that means it has inflection
point
and then you know moving forward why i'm
saying india would play a massive role
moving forward is if you look at other
emerging markets the demographic uh and
the problems are very similar to india
versus if you compare that to us and
china and i think a good benchmark is a
yc if you look at vice you'll see you
know we're building misho for africa
we're building
for pakistan or bangladesh
and uh and talking about the reverse
brain train pump i think it's very
inevitable once a country reaches
inflection point and what that means it
happened in china
uh i think it was uh david b
uh he said we should be thankful
of
microsoft and what that means 70 percent
of ctos of chinese companies were once
microsoft alumni meaning they moved back
and built massive tech companies similar
thing is happening in india out of
i think yeah we have 105 out of 105 you
know around 40 percent
is again uh
founded or co-founded by the attorneys
and this speed is only going to
accelerate moving forward so uh
in a nutshell
right now
if you think about it you know there's a
lot of unicorns meaning founders and
operators they're getting some liquidity
they're helping their co-workers and
friends starting new companies
that's basically smart capital or the
early employees are leaving and starting
companies and
meaning moving forward the ideas would
be much more
related to india sophisticated and the
speed of execution would be faster so
it's interesting times ahead so when you
talk about uh let's call it 105 unicorns
uh in india that's the third highest uh
anywhere in the world for a country uh
there's about 39 billion dollars to put
that in context in 2019 i think there's
only 11 billion dollars so kind of a
forex increase over a two three year
period uh when you start to think about
that is that capital coming from what
i'll call uh india native venture
capital firms or is this venture capital
firms and angel investors coming from
outside of india and now recognizing the
opportunity in the country and they're
either setting up offices or they're
just coming and visiting and deploying
capital in the country
yeah good question palm so the late
stage has been mostly overseas fund
meeting type tiger o2
and bunch of others softbank
but you know as the ecosystem is
evolving i think someone tweeted
recently they were talking about you
know given the market dynamics right now
i think emerging markets are going to
have a tough time
but i would say it's not true for india
the reason is because
we
have about seven eight funds uh just
this year
combined they have raised over 10
billion so meaning the good capital or
the capital is available it's available
for great companies uh and uh and i
think it's only going to evolve uh to
give you context again
it's it's gonna get difficult it's gonna
be get really hard and competitive in
india and what that means when i moved
back to india
in 2019 from u.s
i joined angellist
to lead business development for them
and then really build out the early
stage investing
you know in the beginning we used to in
fact uh give deals to people you know to
lead syndicates and help them raise
capital fast forward to today now deals
are happening within a day or two so you
can see the scale and again moving
forward you know it's going to get
competitive in india which is a good
great thing for the ecosystem when you
think about the types of companies
obviously uh silicon valley was built on
a very specific type of company now it's
uh expanded uh if you fast forward to
modern day you see this rise of uh kind
of ai or machine learning type
businesses you see a rise in american
dynamism there's kind of these themes
that play out if you look at the indian
ecosystem what are the types of
companies that are really finding
success or the consumer or the
enterprise software do you have a mix of
these different industries what are you
seeing in terms of kind of the vertical
uh popularity this episode is brought to
you by eight sleep good sleep is a game
changer and the eight sleep pod is the
best sleep machine i sleep on it every
single night a great night of sleep
allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself innate sleep you can
go to
eightsleep.compomp today to go ahead and
get 150 off your order eightsleep.com
not only do i sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and i begged
the founders to let me invest in the
company
eightsleep.com go get yourself an eight
sleep pod and get a better night of
sleep
yeah
so in the beginning again it was very
similar to any other emerging market you
copy an idea that has worked somewhere
else and it's easier to get funded and
once you reach a scale again this
capital this talent then you start
building id companies or you start
solving problems that are very specific
to india
and in terms of you know to answer your
question
uh
um
so what the trend that we are seeing
right now again like you know let me
step back a bit in the beginning it was
i t services right we were
giving technology services to companies
outside and we're building software
uh for companies outside and then
you know now
companies global companies actually
building products in india
so they can utilize the same product in
other emerging markets but what we are
seeing next moving forward would be
there will be a lot of b2b sas companies
going global that's been happening uh
you know fresh work is a great chance
that recently went public soho church be
a bunch others like 10 15 now and we're
also seeing
consumer companies going global uh
meaning very you know ready from india
like cars 24 is one of them lens guard
is you know similar to again uh warby
parker but they're dominating the asian
uh asian market uh and it's it's again
it's evolution as the markets get deeper
there's more capital there's more talent
then you go after really really hard
problems because the
risk capital would increase over time
when you think about uh your exact
activities you've got 1947 rise fund
talk a little bit about what the
strategy here is and you're backed by a
just glitterati list of uh investors and
operators and american-based vc funds
how exactly did you go about putting
together that lp list and raising the
capital
yeah
i think
i raised the entire fund through uh cool
tweets called emails
but let me let me give you a quick uh
background bomb
so
you know early life was uh all about
tennis i would say the best decision in
life was picking up tennis uh played
professionally in india won the
nationals used to be one or two in the
country represented india on a few
occasions then i ended up moving to san
diego an attendance scholarship uh you
know i googled san diego for the first
time and i was like okay man this is it
i love the place so i went there
i had a fantastic time played college
tennis you know my teammates were from
15 16 different nationalities and then
introduction to twitter was really a
turning point in life both
professionally and personally and i
think that was 2013 or 2014
and that's when i started following
smart people and just just start
learning from them it's they're right
there
and all you need to do is you should
just have a desire to learn and
implement things
while log pump i came to know about this
event called stocktoberfest
which is organized by
the guy named howard lindsen
i went there i couldn't afford the pass
i was in the restroom trying to figure
out how to get in someone had forgotten
the name tag took the name tag went in
introduced myself and i tweeted at him
saying thanks for organizing the event i
have no idea why he responded to it he
gave me his email address i emailed him
saying how about me as a professional
tennis player give your tennis lesson in
exchange for your expertise in venture
capital
uh he took a shot on still i don't know
but anyway
there on
fast forward to 2018 i started writing a
newsletter called 1947 tech back then
there was no
newsletter on indian technology
ecosystem
the idea for me was to if i were to move
back to india i should know what's going
on in india it gave me enough data
points form because you know you can
kind of learn from things
i was in in the us i could see what's
happening
and then
again like i got super convinced okay
this is the time this is when you should
be moving back to india let's move back
to india and again with the utsa who who
heads angelus india we became friends in
2017. i was literally cheerleading for
him on twitter uh for him and for angel
senior when i came back joined angelis
tried
leading uh started i joined the angel
list and then 2021
is when a lot of dice supporters started
asking me how should we plan uh and not
move back to india and i've been talking
about reverse brain drain since 2018
it's not something new uh and um and and
then yeah let's so for me the idea was i
moved back to india because i want to be
part of the growth story in india
um
why not have others move back and be
part of the india growth story as well
so that's when i started improving
people who have moved back and built
massive tech companies
uh it's been fun uh and by the way pomp
if uh you know if you come on my podcast
whatever that you need to be in india
you get a free tennis lesson
and you can still hang out
but yeah and then yeah so what's the
next step right we've been i've been
creating content i've been helping uh
these folks understand what india is
about how you know what frameworks these
folks have used to move back and build
companies uh what's the next step next
step for me was okay how about i
you know give capital as well not just
content and uh and yeah so again like uh
for me literally from day one was
i you know this is something i ask
myself why whatever i do uh career-wise
um you know
you have to really
basically have to you know i think we
spoke about it uh where you said like
almost everything is a noise you just
need to figure out what's something just
for you
and you know no one else can compete
with you so for me it was very authentic
to what i was doing you know reverse
brain day and i moved back i've been you
know trying to be you know part of the
story and then and then yeah i mean for
for me the fund was okay i want to raise
capital from people that have admired
over the years i start pinging him start
cold emailing literally every person on
this planet is one email away from you
uh all you need to do is you need to be
smart you need to be uh thoughtful uh
when you're sending an email and uh and
yeah so that's uh that's that's how the
fund came along
and when you you keep mentioning reverse
brain drain explain that concept a
little bit more to folks in terms of
what that exactly means and how you're
seeing this play out on the ground
yeah so anyone who has moved to a
different country
for education and then worked for a bit
and then you move back and apply those
learnings in your country so i can give
you a quick analogy uh here bomb so
let's say country a started tennis i'm
from country y i move to country a i
train practice with the best people when
i move back to one country to a certain
extent uh i will have an edge and that's
what i've meant i meant uh about the
reverse brain train yeah and what is the
value of that in india obviously there's
an education component there's a work
experience component but is there also a
kind of a knowledge transfer that you're
seeing when somebody comes back is it
just simply being applied to their own
companies one of the statistics that i
saw as i was doing a little bit of
research which i almost never do for
conversations but i said i feel like i
got to make sure i'm prepared for this
one uh is 40
of the unicorn companies in india have
actually been founded or co-founded by
somebody uh who's gone through this kind
of reverse brain drain so 40
is a pretty big number compared to uh
maybe where i would have thought it
would come in at
yeah so i think few uh i would say a few
reasons one is
when you move to a different country you
are just exposed to people from
different cultures
uh you know
someone from a different country or
different geographies and all that and i
think the experience that you get it
really opens up your own world view and
when you start something uh you know
from scratch i think culture is very
very important and i think that's where
that skill comes in uh secondly i would
say
you know this bunch of companies
actually uh you know in india or funds
that were you know so i'll give you a
quick example now i was chatting with uh
you know uh
a fun a gp name saloni
she came back and she founded
the first
gaming and entertainment uh
fund
in india and the way it all came down
was she was already she founded a
company in uh in england in in
in gaming space she worked at a fund
that was focused only on gaming she saw
the opportunity similar things are going
to happen in india and she came and and
she was literally the best person to do
that and then that's and she's doing
great so i think these are the few
learnings i would say that i've seen
give me an example of kind of the
quintessential indian startup today and
kind of what that path looks like is
there one that sticks out in your mind
that you can kind of help people not in
india actually understand how this is
working
um against bomb i i didn't get the
question
can you give us an example of like uh uh
indian startup that you're like this is
the uh perfect you know kind of uh
company story that we're seeing so a
founder leaves they go and get education
or work experience somewhere else they
come back they start a business it
specifically solves a problem in india
and then it scales to a large size like
is there one story that sticks out to
you as a great example
yeah so this couple actually uh there's
one she moved back and the for him the
reason was
he didn't get his uh
his visa approved his name is kunal
behel uh and he's definitely you know
one of the most influential founder in
india now he came back and he built this
company called snapdeal uh
again the learnings from the uh from the
us and and he's been also
enabling the ecosystem through uh
investing there's another guy who came
back
uh you know he went after building uh
i would say sofi
uh in india i had him on my podcast
recently uh again the learnings i
saw those patents in us came back and
went after these problems uh these are
the few that comes to mind and when you
see that kind of story happening the
employees that work at that business are
they mostly from india or are these
global workforces and they're going
outside of india to hire talent as well
yeah so they're mostly india because you
have to have talent from india i think
it's it works the best once you have
there's a combination of someone coming
back uh you know applies learnings back
home and someone who has always been in
india
so that's their uh you know most of
these uh
uh you know employees are from here but
what i see is
many times the talent that has moved
back there they still have connections
overseas that could help them raise
capital that could help them uh hire
good talent they can come back i've seen
this play out here
what's going on with bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies in the country
i think you know you gotta have uh jd on
your podcast
he's the the founder of polygon but uh
i i really don't know it's it's mostly
about
wait and watch i'm personally i'm
bullish on the technology uh and and the
talent the talent density is a lot
uh another thing i would say palm
uh something interesting that happened
to india in web free spaces is really uh
jd and sandeep building polygon and
they're really really
enabling the ecosystem what that means
they are funding other companies uh you
know they have funds now lined up
they've been investing they've been
helping so it's it's really again the
ecosystem uh that's been building and
it's there to say and web3 is global
right uh you could be anywhere it could
be hiring anywhere
and when you think about something like
bitcoin cryptocurrencies how important
is it for uh there to be one example
like you mentioned polygon as okay there
is one example all the other
entrepreneurs see that this is possible
to happen in india and then do you see a
big rush of uh kind of entrepreneurs
fast following into an industry
yeah so in fact uh pomp i was
having a conversation with one of the
investors
where there was a trend that i was
seeing uh i would say you know the last
three four months the good talent was
actually migrating to web3 and what that
means either they were founding
companies in web 3 or they were joining
web 3 companies so to me that's just a
validation and again like you should be
just following the smart talent what you
know where they're headed to and then
that's where you can really you know
kind of have a sense and and go after it
and then talk to me about uh this
conversation there's gonna be a lot of
indian entrepreneurs uh or even folks
who work in the tech industry uh from
india maybe they live there or maybe
they are still kind of abroad what's
your message to them as to why maybe
they should either come home uh or start
a business uh in india today's episode
is brought to you by alto ira have you
wanted to buy bitcoin or over 200 other
cryptocurrencies in your retirement
account well now you can with alto ira
they allow you to buy bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies in a tax-advantaged way
there's no account or setup fees and
it's super simple to get started you can
go today to alto
ira.com to get started alto ira.com
invest in bitcoin or cryptocurrencies in
your retirement account and get all the
tax advantages while still holding
digital currencies alto ira.com
yeah so you know again like i was i was
interviewing one of the guys he's moved
back and he's built a billion dollar
company
he said uh you know india is a movie not
a picture
and and one should
you know stay at it for long enough and
and you'll you'll get what you deserve
so it hasn't even started uh with his
business
you know he told me shiva when pandemic
hit
we thought it's going to be bad for the
business but it was actually the
opposite what ended up happening
uh you know from 400k users to i think
within
you know few months they got to i think
about three to four
million users
and uh
and you know we were just in general
talking about okay you know if people
are thinking about moving back to india
the traditional advice is it it's either
now or never but the reality is india is
only getting better and what that means
so he said you know the digital
revolution that we saw in the last two
years was way was probably more than
what we've seen in the previous six
years and the next two years would be
even faster uh and the foundation has
already been laid right these
technologies have been built so at a
base level i'll talk about the levers
you know how it all happened so one is
geo geo came in and it literally just
brought india to the internet now we
have about almost 800 internet users
upi came along that really digitized the
uh the payment system in india it's
actually the most sophisticated payment
system in the world right now
and then aadhaar came along it really
digitized the identity of digital
identity so the point is
the foundations are laid
and and this talent there is capital so
now it will be easier to come back and
build companies and their they'll be
scalable they'll be faster
and yeah i mean i think i'm pumped uh
it's gonna be interesting times ahead
talk to me about uh 1947 rise fund when
are you trying to meet founders is it
pre-seed seed series a what size checks
are you looking to write and any
specific types of companies you're
looking for yeah
so i'm focused on reverse brain drain
talent and highly ambitious indian
founders
i come in at three seat and seat
uh i'm sector agnostic for me it all
comes down to the team uh and the and
then the big market and team is really
about back to that thing like you just
have to have that thing okay this is
just for me and and just no one can
compete against me
and that's you know really the kind of
people that i'm looking for got it and
then in terms of how people can get in
touch with you where should we send them
uh to find you on the internet
so i'm there on twitter
uh shiva is someone dm is open feel free
to i love sliding into other people's dm
so feel free
and on the newsletter what should people
get from that is that just uh something
that you're putting out in terms of
trends and it'll be valuable to
investors that aren't based in india as
well if they want to know what's going
on within the country or is it
specifically targeted for folks that are
in the country of india
yeah so it's
anyone who's
looking to keep updated with the indian
technology ecosystem it's a five-minute
read and i curate the top news that
happened in that week uh in the
ecosystem basically
got it uh before i let you go you
mentioned my friend howard lindsen
earlier and i wasn't gonna let you get
away with uh can you say one good thing
and one bad thing about howard so i can
cut this clip and then send it to him
and make fun of him
you know i think one thing that i
learned from him
is
you know i had only read about it which
is
you know many times
high performance uh there's nothing
crazy crazy about them
but i think one thing which is very hard
to do is what i see in him is it doesn't
matter how he's feeling uh he's gonna
just show up he's gonna be there he's
gonna do the work and that's something
that i picked up from him
and then i think uh on the other side
yeah i think he just needs to get better
at tennis
[Laughter]
i was gonna say he's not funny because i
know that will actually hurt his
feelings but not being good at tennis is
probably the second best thing uh no
howard is amazing
he tries to being funny but but yeah
yeah
he is the uh the funniest not funny
investor uh that we have so we'll we'll
take it um is there anything that uh uh
anything else that i missed or anything
that you think people should know about
the indian ecosystem
uh again uh for i think it's a very very
exciting uh you know times in india
especially if you're looking to build
from india
uh and then not just that even if you're
looking to expand to india this massive
market
uh but another thing is bomb
uh i think my friend uh alfonso is is
asking me he has a question for you
uh he's saying what needs to be true
uh
for pong to come to india
so people i think most people know uh i
came to india in i think it was 2015
uh if i remember correctly and i spent
two weeks in the country i absolutely
loved it my brother and i went to i
think five different cities and um we
did uh we did everything man it was uh
an absolute blast and uh folks always
say like what do you mean you did
everything and i'm like look we went we
saw some of the tech scene in bangalore
uh we went and we spent new year's eve
in goa on the beach uh we were yeah
exactly right like we had we had plenty
of fun um we were up in uh in delhi uh
we went to uh the monkey temple we
literally got motorcycles this is a
great story for you
we got motor we rented motorcycles and
we were driving and for anyone who's
never been to india before if you think
that new york city traffic or somewhere
else is bad there are places in india
where traffic is absolutely uh uh just
unbearable but the thing that's crazy is
if you're on a motorcycle
traffic does not work the same way it
works in the us and so uh you're kind of
like you know okay i'm supposed to be
enjoying this but i'm also trying not to
die right now but it was this amazing
experience because then we went uh to
all these different places and uh it's a
country that if i had to kind of just
like pull out a couple of themes i think
one uh from demographics very young
country right there there's a lot of
young people and and uh they're very uh
ambitious uh but the energy within the
country uh is just incredible like it
was a place where there's only two times
uh that i've really gone on a trip uh
and spent a lot of time uh meeting with
founders and entrepreneurs and walked
away with this feeling one time was in
india one time was in nigeria and they
both have a lot of similarities in terms
of demographics and and kind of hitting
an inflection point
but uh in india specifically uh it just
felt like people were there
uh building companies and
there was this feeling of inevitable
success like we as a group are going to
be successful some companies will work
some companies won't but like we as a
group will be successful and i took it
away uh and when i came back to the
united states i remember saying to
myself like a special place
right and uh i think that that was
probably uh a trip that
it's like why would i not go back so
it's less about like will i come back
and it's more about when will i come
back but i need to set up now i'm like
feel more educated so i need to set up
kind of a whole little trip throughout
the country uh so that i can actually
see people that i know uh at the time i
only knew one person uh which was uh
kind of crazy to go there and not really
know anybody uh but now i feel like the
trip would be even more fun than the
first time i went
yeah no absolutely a lot has changed
pomp since 2015. it will be different
country that you'll be seeing and agree
with you that you know the again like
the i think the median age is 27 year
old and highly highly aspirational
another thing is i think you know a
story or
or a theme or
now it's a slogan can really change a
country's
i think the prime minister of india has
done a great great job uh you know he
started the slogan startup india
and and i think that's helping uh india
really i would say that's helping
startups go mainstream in india and if
you combine all of these things which is
highly aspirational young
and tech talent uh that becomes very
powerful so yeah we'll it'll be
interesting and uh and to your point to
traffic i think uh
you know the folks in india are very
patient uh yeah
[Laughter]
it uh uh
it's one of these things that uh every
place at traffic in l.a sucks traffic in
miami sucks right uh new york city sucks
uh you go anywhere in europe traffic
sucks like it is a universal experience
of sitting in traffic nobody likes but
that is uh one of the downsides to uh to
growth and uh you know where there's no
traffic it's where people don't want to
live right so at some point uh traffic
is actually a sign that uh something's
going right um listen this is a
fantastic conversation i really enjoyed
it uh i feel like to some degree uh in a
positive way it feels like you know it's
india versus the world right and india
is still obviously very collaborative
but uh uh there's a ton of great stuff
going on there so uh for those that are
listening uh or watching that have not
done kind of work on on the indian
ecosystem i highly suggest that you do
it i think that your twitter and
newsletter are a great place to uh to
get started and then folks who obviously
are in india uh which is actually i
don't think you know this one of the top
three countries uh that consume the
podcast uh but for those that are um uh
in india uh and they're building company
they should definitely reach out to you
and uh hopefully you know you'll be
raising more money over time and uh and
continue investing in the ecosystem
yeah no absolutely and one one last
thing
uh you know someone is new and they're
traveling to india this is how you
should be thinking about india in terms
of technology
uh if you are looking to hire talent
just go to bangalore that's where the
talent density is
if you are looking to build a sas
company go to chennai uh that's where
you know fresh works came out from zoho
charge b and bunch others now the
network effect is kicking in if you're
looking to sell products and markets or
trying or looking to set up a shop
for sales or business development delhi
nci is the place and then the mumbai
mumbai is you know it's a blend of la
which is again the culture or the movie
bollywood uh amazing music
and uh and then the new york so it's a
combination of la and new york
i love it all right my friend i
appreciate it very much thank you and we
would definitely do this again in the
future as uh india continues to progress
absolutely thanks a lot pompa had a
great time